this is a production of Cornell
University
I've been in Cee for seven years now
um coming from a a postdoc in uh
environmental biogeochemistry at epfl in
Switzerland which I'll talk a little bit
about and so yeah so um the topic is on
biogeochemistry of Arsenic and rice
paddy soils I was telling Lou I sent
that title in the summer I think I was
still in denial about the semester
starting so I just sent a very generic
title because I didn't want to decide
what I wanted to talk about so I have a
little bit of a focusing uh sort of
subtitle here on the role of dissolved
organic matter and microbial arsenic
transformations
so
um my my group over in civil and
environmental engineering is on
biogeochemistry and ecosystem
engineering and we have kind of like two
broad research themes that we that we
pursue in my lab one is on nature-based
systems for controlling non-point Source
nitrogen
um
uh from agriculture also some Urban
storm water so this is things like
constructed Wetlands bio filtration
um this is a wood ship woodship
bioreactor
um at a farm uh near near Cornell and
the other uh research area that my group
pursues is in the microbial
biogeochemistry of Arsenic and a lot of
that work is motivated by the problem of
um arsenic uptake into rice and trying
to understand those processes better
especially from a below ground
perspective like what are the soil
biogeochemical processes that are
controlling the speciation
toxicity and fate of Arsenic and rice
paddy soil
environments and so sometimes people and
I'll be talking about this today so
sometimes people ask you how you know
especially from environmental
engineering
that I get involved working with rice so
as a graduate student
here I was working in
um wetlands in in New Jersey so New
Jersey wetlands are a great place to
study pollutant Dynamics in Wetland
environments and so here's a picture we
were doing some work and uh
um winter time in the New Jersey
Meadowlands which you see if you sort of
drive on any of the highways around sort
of Northern New Jersey
and a lot of what we were doing was you
know thinking about actually focusing in
on the Wetland rhizosphere
um the release of oxygen from a rental
Wetland Roots into anaerobic Wetland
soils the formation of these oxic anoxic
interfaces in the subsurface and how
that affects cycling of redox sensitive
metals like iron and the coupling of
that to other biogeochemical processes
and we're also interested in how this
this sort of gas transfer conduit can
also facilitate the release of methane
and nitrous oxide
um so then after that I did what you
know what one does when they're
interested in aquatic chemistry I moved
to Switzerland for a postdoc at epfl
and as I was discussing
projects with my postdoctoral advisor
Roslyn Bernier lemani who's actually a
Cornell undergraduate Alum she mentioned
that they were just beginning a new
research collaboration and partnership
with some groups in in Vietnam and this
was part of a uh like francophone
uh research initiative called rescue
here what you know why was Vietnam
involved in this francophone research
Network because of the sort of older
Colonial uh history in Vietnam
um and part of this um sort of this
Asian Center of water research so this
is a sort of a map that shows sort of
this like research Network connecting
different different francophone
um research institutions
um including ones in Vietnam and that's
how it started we go from kind of like
cold New Jersey snowy Wetlands to sort
of tropical Mekong Delta um rice paddy
um environment sort of like connected by
the theme of sort of biogeochemical
processes and flooded soil flooded soil
environments
okay
and of course so talking about uh rice
and arsenic a lot of that work that I
was interested in starting in the mid
sort of mid-2010s a lot of that came out
of you know important work that happened
in this department okay in the group of
John Duxbury
um which was some of the first work to
identify the the problem of high arsenic
concentrations in rice but then also
importantly
um
identified that
um we have to look Beyond total Arsenic
and we have to think about arsenic
speciation okay to think about what are
the concentrations of inorganic arsenic
species and the concentrations of
methylated arsenic species so this is
monomethyl arsenic where one of the
hydroxyls is substituted by one methyl
group and then a die dma I'll be talking
about dma a lot a dimethyl arsenic with
two with two methyl groups okay and what
was found here was that uh rice
using Market Basket surveys there could
be a large variability in the methylated
Arsenic concentration but the inorganic
concentration
seems to not change
okay so this is a really important early
work motivating
um why we should try to understand the
Dynamics of the calculated species
better in the soil because the rice
plants themselves are not capable of
Liquidators the methylated Arsenic is
formed
primarily from microbial transportations
okay there are some Organic pesticides
which are to use which can produce
species but for the most part we think
these are produced by by microbial biome
activation reactions that happened
so it okay so
um
there are three parts in The Talk today
I'll start in the first part of the kind
of kind of bigger overview of the
problem of Arsenic and rice paddy soil
isn't much too practical efforts are to
deal with it and this is meant partially
to provide just a demo overview of
particular topic and then we'll talk
about some
okay
become green or it stays red
[Music]
um
thank you
you hear me now anyone I guess
for the zoom comment there
um
so then sort of then uh dive into some
more Focus research here on the effects
of dissolved organic methylation and
then we'll wrap up
um
yeah so
um this is a x-ray fluorescence map of
um some rice paddy soil from Arkansas
and it shows the sort of the
co-locations of arsenic iron and things
Okay so
so co-locations of Arsenic and iron at
this yellow
it's yellow color and so what you'll see
is that there's
um quite a bit of yellow especially
around the edges of some of these these
mineral greens okay and what that's kind
of like I think this is something that's
been known for some time is that um
arsenic strongly absorbs onto the
surface of iron oxidants okay so I want
to understand uh sort of processes
regulating the solubility of arsenic
mobility and bioavailability the first
thing we have to think about
um
okay so we also went and did some Zanes
Spectra on some hot spots here so you
can see some of these
pois like points of interest like two
three six
around these yellow colors you can see
that uh so this is some arsenic veins
that the um sort of the Zane Spectrum
it's very similar to a therahydrate
Commerce
okay so arsenic five is a really
important post
or um arsenic soil you'll also see in
some of these cases here
where there's these you can kind of see
them it may be these like really small
red dots right like super hot for
arsenic but not associated with iron or
manganese a lot of bees have a spectrum
similar to Arsenal Tyrant okay or like
uh iron arsenic sulfide mineral and
that's because arsenic also has a high
affinity for first culture
okay
so what can often happen is there'll be
this toothpaste process if the soil goes
from
oxygen conditions
if you think about a well-drained oxic
soil arsenic tends not to be mobile it's
boundaries oxide surfaces
flooded and becomes anaerobic we have
reductive dissolution
and also mobilization
so it's very common
correlation between dissolving iron and
dissolve arsenic in Wetland or rice
paddy so or water because the the
reductive dissolution you iron controls
one of these arsenic okay
at the same time
if you had systems high and sold faith
that becomes sulphitic you can sulfide
then the reaction of saltified RC 1902
to produce prasino pyrite but also so
we're also to produce like mechanical
white iron sulfide nucleus and our
spring causes resolution
so these sort of like the big picture
there's a lot of recognition that iron
is important for arsenic Dynamics
software is important for arsenic
Mobility
this happens and we get mobile and
bioavailable Personnel just one reason
why that the principle reason why rice
is so good and taking the Arsenic
because it's growing and flooded soil
conditions okay
so it's known that this is a problem so
when I first started it for now
um I had a collaborative project that
the owner's National price Research
Center in eastern Arkansas which is
where most of the rights in the United
States has grown on some of their
efforts to basically try to control the
bioavailability of arsenic who basically
controlling irrigation okay so rather
than grow rice continuously in flooded
occasions do something called alternate
wedding and dry which is to periodically
drain soils
um oxidized soil sort of like reverse
this process
okay
um and then what we did is we we
collected uh four water samples we
monitor the poor water geochemistry
during these alternative budgeting
experiments we also collected soil
samples
um to take the singer charms to put a
kind of a presentation
so
here's just an example of what we've
seen because we have three Fields this
field this shows the volumetric water
content this field was
flooded for the entire season this field
Experience One dry down before being
reflected this feeling experienced two
dry downs and so what you can see is if
you look at the iron concentrations
you know we see this increase in the
iron concentration continuously flooded
fields are in these anaerobic throughout
the future growing season okay error
bars are big all right because we're
looking at sort of appliances
the trends are pretty clear
we look at this one drain field you can
see the iron is increasing and then this
dry down is pretty effectively at
knocking those ions this is all that
concentrations down and then they do
start to accumulate a little afterwards
and then you see the same pattern here
where
iron increases the dry down decreases
so you can effectively control
basically an iron redox reactions
through these various practical water
level treatments of the fatty soils
concentrations total arsenic
concentration so we can see here in a
permanently flooded field arsenic
concentrations are relatively High you
know there's a lot of variability but we
do see a high mean
um we've got soil that's drained once we
see arsenic is increasing and then it's
very effectively controlled through even
just this one mid-season drain event
because I start to come over here a
little bit at the end okay so from a
sort of below ground perspective we see
that these water level treatments
arsenic concentrations
But ultimately we care about like what's
how much is getting into the race right
that's sort of like a practical endpoint
um we are concerned with so we also
sampled the rice grains and performed
nursing speciation analysis of the rice
grains and so here are five different
rice
um cultivars okay
um that were selected by our USDA
collaborators
um in some of their like reading efforts
also kind of
um you know use breeding to select for
strains that are excluders of Arsenic
and so the red here shows the DNA that
methylated arsenic concentration and the
sort of teal color here shows that
inorganic
and so what we see is that
and this is sort of the zero dreams
continuously saturated and finance
monitoring so the drains are effective
at decreasing the total arsenic
concentrations in some cases okay so
that's good news but the less good news
is that they're only effective at really
changing and methylated nursing and
concentrations while the inorganic
arsenic concentrations are fairly stable
okay across all of these different
drainage
um treatments and even across the
different cultures
okay and this is actually sort of
consistent with what we saw in that
paper from John Doc's greatest group in
2008 using a Market Basket survey that
we see variability in dma or inorganic
arsenic astrology constant here we see
something similar when we're looking at
different cultivars you know different
irrigation treatments but from this
nature instead of this term
okay so we see that AWD did not have a
significant effect arsenic levels
um inorganic arsenic is actually the
more
so it's a little bit controversial but
inorganic are thought to be the more
toxic form of arsenic so what we have in
terms of like sort of Mason regulations
about arsenic rice
um especially this is primarily focused
on
arsenic concentrations in human foods
rice crackers things like that how to
focus on only in organic person okay and
this is similar to the regulatory
structures in
China or also in Europe where the
regulations Focus only on endogenic
personally
so basically if there's a concern or the
goal is different is to control
inorganic arsenic concentrations for the
most part ultimate wedding drive is not
very effective
but it does raise questions about like
what's happening during these dry down
events so that interrogen of our stable
well either arsenic concentrations
are highly variable
I also want to mention really that there
are a variety of objectives with
ultimate avoiding and trying one is
control of our state another is control
of many okay rice paddies are really
significant Global Sources of methane
emissions
and these wedding drying Cycles are also
are effective as Physicians
they also say water okay so there's a
variety of reasons why we might want to
introduce this type of alternate putting
and drying
um practice beyond the motivations for
arsenic
okay
so there are also large scale variations
in sort of methylated arsenic fractions
regionally so if you look at here in the
U.S the us growing rice tends to have a
higher method bursting fraction Bryce
Ronin Asia tends to have a lower
conversion fraction these patterns are
not well understood and at all okay and
this is from a paper and I was 10 years
old but in the in the past there haven't
been much
um actually advancement understanding
why
so for the rest of the talk we'll sort
of do like kind of like a deep focused
dive on this process here how is
inorganic partisan converted into ethic
nursing species that your rice fatty
rhizosphere you know what are the
factors that control this this
process
that's basically controlling how much
DNA
how much arsenite are available for
low ground
look at these evaluations
Okay so
um a lot of what I'll talk about now is
the student John has done and so as I
mentioned there's been a lot of research
over the past 10 years research using
metabolic inhibition of different
microbial metabolisms to try to link
methylation to a specific sort of
functional group like is it is it
related to sulfate reduce services
that has not been particularly
inclusive
um possible lack of work looking parts
and the functions which came first
translation diversity that can you can
learn things from RSM University it
turns out that our stand is extremely
diverse okay so it's hard to link the
the sort of the the genetic potential
for Arsenal populations in any specific
sort of microbial functional group
so what we did is we sort of okay
let's step back
to Basics how does Arsenal compilation
RSM the RSM Prime that methylates
arsenic is an intracellular
enzyme so in order for arsenic to get
methylated first has to get into
microbial cells okay
how does Arsenic get into
okay depending on the oxidation Theta
Varsity arsenate can enter cells through
phosphate Transporters because of
chemical similarities
phosphate okay but in reducing system
the predominant form of arsenic is
actually a Phi theological and arsenite
is uh neutral there's a pka of round
nine so in most environmental soils it's
uncharged and it enters cells through
glpf Transporters and glpf Transporters
typically take up
uncharged small carbon molecules
glycerol or glycine or sugars
so
we decided to sort of think about you
know what's happening here
thinking about how arsenite gets into
cells so that it can be methylated
into DNA
and one of the tools that we've used is
an arsenic biosensor okay so an arsenic
biosensor is a engineered E coli to
produce fluorescent proteins and arsenic
is taken up into cells okay so you can
use this to sort of
um
um you know so this is a fluorescence
microscope image of these biosensor
cells see if you see here these cells
like lighting up the red that's because
they're expressing these fluorescent
proteins because they have our
spectating on the side so this work has
been done in collaboration but how it's
more on that University of Iowa is a
microbiology Institute who developed
these biosensor cells and so basically
we can measure the intensity of the
fluorescence as a quantitative measure
of how much arsenic is taking the cells
or how quickly are saying so
and we first started
um using this technique to understand
you know what role does dissolved
organic matter play in complexing
Arsenic
you know possibly through sulfur ligands
possibly through colloid formation
um
and that's something that is limiting
the bioavailability of Varsity so we
can't get any size
so
um one application of this was to
think about toxic and oxygen interfaces
soil that are produced when we have
these wedding drying Cycles also these
boxes the interfaces that can occur kind
of thing arises here where there's
oxygen released from Roots into
anaerobic soil environments and the for
and the production of these sort of like
fe3 and om we're having to MLM colloids
okay
um
produced in the lab and then through a
point to micron filter okay and it's
important because uh often we think
about the filtered concentration as sort
of like uh dissolves fractions
bioavailable interaction and it passes
through these 22.9 filter and so what
Eon showed really well is it that's not
really true at all
um so we looked at
different
arsenic to carbon ratios so the Arsenic
concentration fixed so increasing
concentrations of dissolved organic
matter
and then also looking at the iron three
to carbon ratio as iron three
concentrations increased and you can
basically look at the size of the bubble
as a measure of arsenada
okay using the biases so 100 is sort of
like you know what we see in the absence
of any Dom or iron
and as we go to sort of higher D1
concentrations and also higher iron
concentrations you see the Arsenic
uptake increase
uh or the yeah sorry you see the Arsenic
update decrease the amount of inhibition
increase until here we actually get to
these points where at high ION three and
high Dom there's actually no arsenic
octane at all arsenic octane is a
completely suppressed in these
conditions even though the Arsenic is
still like in a dissolved Direction
quite interesting results
so one process which might be limiting
um arsenic uptake into cells and
transformation is sort of compensation
with dom or complexation or partitioning
onto iron to be called The Waves which
are stabilized by the presence of salt
rice paddies are very rich in as long as
organic matter that's the reason why
there such important source of the
methane okay
and so we also then were interested in
the role of sulfur-rich Dom
due to the role of thiol ligands and
complexing arsenic Imaging earlier than
arsenic is a high affinity for sulfur
okay so bioligans and this operand
matter have a very high Affinity foreign
here and so what we saw is across a
range of arsenic concentrations when we
increased the the bile to arsenic ratio
we saw decreasing uptake of arsenic okay
so basically more Dom
in that previous figure
but one interesting thing here we saw
here was
this Upper Mississippi river natural
organic matter which is uh reverse
osmosis isolate um river water from the
Mississippi River
has a relatively High organic silver
content but it was able to achieve
significant decreases in Arsenic uptake
at much lower biles arsenic ratios than
the lithium right the work with
glutathione told us that you need a very
large excess of ions to actually see a
meaningful inhibition of arsenic uptake
we didn't need such a large excess in
the presence of Mississippi
so this suggests an inhibition mechanism
other than arsenic complexation with
Biology
so complexation plays a role here but it
might not be lost
and so what might also be happening
um
is there some like biological response
together as well as a sort of like a
chemical compensation
and what we saw was that we look at OD
600 so we look at cell growth the cell
growth is stimulated in the presence of
the Mississippi Nom when it's not easy
stimulated in the presence
okay so this is telling us that there's
biolabile carbon in that mnom pool that
we don't see
okay
so this
um
made us think about the possibility of
some type of carbon metabolic depression
okay so what is carbon metabolic
regression okay so this is something
that's
um
relatively well known in the
environmental engineering World
especially with regard to degradation of
organic foods okay and what's been shown
is that
if cells are in sort of very ligotrophic
low carbon environments they tend to
actually be better at degradation of
like xenobiotic organic foods and the
theory is that if the cells are
experiencing these sort of like
starvation conditions they'll start to
actually over Express a lot of their
transport channels overexpress a lot of
their concatening enzymes because
they're just sort of Desperately looking
for and I'm describing them on a certain
personal relative to the cells and
obviously is such a significant
physiological response okay and what's
also been shown is that if you then
increase the lay biocarbon
concentrations the efficiency of micro
gluten degradation
tends to decrease okay and the idea is
that if they're in an environment
replete with carbon substrates complete
with food they don't need to devote as
many of their resources to actually
acquiring that
okay so you're basically interested in
testing whether this Theory could
explain some of these variations right
because arsenic is taken up through this
geoc transport doesn't also take up low
molecular weight carbon Associates
okay so could there be some like
interaction here between like the Dom
pool
the play biofraction of the EOS
and indirect effects on arsenic objects
okay so anyway so here's basically the
question here does carbon if you have
like repression play a role in
regulating microbial arsenic
Transformations through control of
course
through Transporters that principally
take up our humans
so we um
prepared
um Tom solution to the range of
concentrations from this Mississippi Nom
and also from the prices throughout the
change
um relevant for the types of Dom eum
inputs into a race environment and we
used the E coli biosensor method as well
as
looking at expression of the Gopi to
transporter using protein PCR
and so we saw it here
with the Mississippi nlm sort of
consistent with what we expected from
before as we increase the Dom or doc
concentration that this is showing the
varsity uptake rate we see this decrease
in the Arsenic uptake we're at very high
doc concentrations actually contagious
including activated
um
and for the rice straw DJ we see a
similar Trend but the effect is not as
significant as what we saw for this this
is to be you know when
in both cases it according to know if we
see eom is stimulating silver okay so
and so it has an indication that there
is quantity
then when we looked at the expression of
the
the glpf transporter is basically how
actively our cells maintain or of these
cell membrane or membrane transport
channels
you can see here there is a repression
of glpf expression in the presence of
fnom
we see a somewhat different pattern
where initially you see an increase in
glpf expression but then at these
highest doc concentrations you do see
this strong regression in that
expression and it's notable that we have
the sort of significant jump in cell
growth at these two highest doc
concentrations just the same doc
concentrations where we see the most
significant efficient of repression of
the transferences so just from this one
example there that doesn't do some
connection between certainly to what
extent has both stimulated and to what
extent is a gopm expression
okay so um
yeah so higher Tom represses glpf
expression
um and repressed Geographic Expressions
also Associated less biosensor
okay so we wanted to take it uh one step
further and also look at methylation
okay everything I've talked about so far
has really been about I'll take how does
Arsenal came out he doesn't get into
cells does this translate into effects
on actually production
so we use this
um this cell an arsenistic Vector
Roseanne which was isolated from Rice
padding soil and this
um cell lacks an RSB influx problem so
most cells will take arsenic up and then
they'll extrude it and actually very
rapidly to detoxify it this micro lacks
this um e plus so what that means is the
Arsenic concentrations accumulating in
the cell and so it becomes so it's a
very definition
okay so we kind of use this as a tool to
study
um sort of what might be affecting uh
production method or actually because of
the methods box so it's kind of easy to
see how easier
and then we we use that with hplc icpms
as I look at the
to look at the changes in our
specification
and so basically you know we then
um using this our sensor vector roseni
perform this biomethylation assay as
well as for back expression function
gene or depression manipulation
and so for natural organic matter
um so really consistent
nice consistency with our earlier
results okay as doc increases the method
so that this is the methylation
efficiency so this is like the the
fraction of arsenic that's evaluated
normalized by modes
okay so we're trying to account and
normalize for differences in cell growth
that might result from different levels
of dissolved mechanic carbon so we see
you know a decrease in our introduction
in ventilated arsenic species as these
creases which is sort of consistent
information for and we also see a
decrease in uh Mars and expression okay
or some expression is induced by the
endocytical Arsenic so it makes sense
that a varsity cells and arsenic
expression will also be done so all of
this is buried telling a kind of
consistent story
and thinking about the biosensor results
right we're similarly C where uptake
isn't shut off as we're measuring the
biosensor we're also seeing basically no
management
okay so the results with the light with
the rice straw leachate the are not are
not as sort of a consistently small okay
what we see with methylation deficiency
is an initial increase followed by
a sort of
possibly decreasing China's make it to
higher DLC but not really but not not
meaningfully returning levels in the
control similarly when you look at the
expression of ours and we see this
increasing and then decrease tracks okay
so what we're seeing here is with the
form of the
domain this Mississippi Noms having a
more significant a more clear
intimidating effect
s keychain
and um so some main points here
you know we saw that higher deal and it
went for Christ's genome expression
uptake
and then at least for the mnom we saw a
deepest expression
for the right strategy is bad
and um or actively now what other
sources that dissolve organic matter
typically Dom with different diversity
and just it just kind of like wrap
things up here who's kind of like a
conceptual model
the idea or the theory is that with low
biolay biocarbon the cells will Express
more glpf Transporters in order to
acquire and more you know
low molecular weight carbon substrates
that will inadvertently lead to more
arsenic conversation
in contrast
there's a lot of carbon
you know less dedication of resources to
taking up carbon right leading to less
um fewer Pathways for our students
picture
that's the theory that we're have some
support and we're continuing to test
so I presented this for the first time
over the summer at the ultimate
conference but there's a lot of interest
in our stipulation and you can see a lot
of people in the audience just like but
but but we know that organic matter
tends to stimulate
so what you're saying is really contrary
to a lot of established college and so I
think the point I just want to make to
kind of put this into context is that I
think our message is that Arsenal
cupcake per cell we would expect to
decrease as violated organic carbonate
increases if our theory is correct okay
but we also know that if we have more
violabial organic carbon we'll also have
more microbial Bionics
okay so we have these two different sort
of like factors that are sort of acting
in contrary directions
so like what is the what is the net
result
um you know it's quite likely that at
low carbon concentration you might see
this this stimulus of arsenic
methylation but then what happens you
see a plateau and we see an increase and
then a decrease I think is the sort of
like the question that we're now trying
to understand
interestingly when I was at the
Goldsmith conference I saw a
presentation where someone was
presenting data exactly like this
um where they saw
um they were looking at a Chrono
sequence of soil Patty soils from China
with a radiant and Doc concentrations
and basically they saw it as a field
increased even how do you soil or water
they saw an initial increase in the
Arsenic methylation qualified plateau
whereas a lot of the traditional
thinking would be that you can sort of
continue to see this increase due to
stimulus of microbial growth
and they had just gotten their neighbor
rejected because this pattern s or
anything interesting
it's just any
uh prior knowledge and they had no
education
yeah
afterwards okay so
um I'm running out of time here so I'll
just briefly run through the last few
slides
um which is to say that so a lot of what
I've talked about so far is about our
methylation a lot of the research is
about our specification but that's not
really the whole story right we also
have to think about our
so
when we talk about you know what's
leading to high concentrations of VMA
traditionally people have thought we
have to understand at least we have to
understand the expression of course
maybe that's totally misguided right
maybe it's really about demonstration
right maybe demethylation is actually
controlling
okay but it's not really about equations
combination
both
there was a finding here of uh of a new
arsenic Gene RSI which is a carbon
versus colitis this um it requires
molecular oxygen is a DI oxygenase okay
so maybe this explains what's happening
in the alternate lighting and drawing
why when you dry the soil down you see a
decrease in the methylated
arsonic okay but this is less relevant
for flooded soil
um so we sort of
we sort of accidentally came across this
interesting finding where we were using
uh metabolic inhibition
um inhibiting the phantogenesis to try
to understand
human connections play a role in our
simplification
okay so we use this methanogenic
inhibitor called genius okay and what we
saw here was that
um
when we use PES okay so when BTS was
used and methanogenesis was inhibited we
saw the dma concentration sort of
continuously increase okay when when the
phenogenesis was not inhibited
DNA increased and then and then
decreased okay so this we were thinking
okay there's an advantages be involved
in rcd metals actually right
um does that make sense okay so about
the time
my student first showed me this graph
that was really really beautiful study
in Disney that I'm super jealous of
where they use a 13c labeled Medical
Group on dma and track that 13c methyl
into methane which suggested indeed the
thanogens are somehow utilizing the
carbon in this DNA Maple group as a
substrate from appendages
really really nice
great study
um and it is sort of like consistent
with what we found
um sort of separately
um so basically right the question now
is is DNA a carbon substrate for
methodologies methylotropic phenogens
utilize methyl groups in
um small compounds like methanol
this is dimethylamine also called DNA to
make things more confusing
okay and so why not why not why why not
why not DNA
you know could the methyl group of this
DNA also comes
so uh Dion developed and executed this
really nice study where we uh added TMA
with DNA uh to sort of test whether
stimulation of methylotropicana Genesis
could lead to against uh denetellation
of dma
so we sort of grew up this this
methylotropic methanogenic community by
adding TMA periodically once we saw an
increase in methane production we call
this day Zero
dimethyl arsenic was Spike and then we
monitored
DNA deintellation and we also so an RNA
sample periography expression so I'm
really running out of time so uh cutting
to the chase
what we see again is that when Nevada
Genesis is prohibited
dma concentrations are fairly stable
okay when the barogenesis occurs we see
a decrease in dma and in the community
that was sort of stimulated with
trimethylamine we see an earlier onset
in a sort of faster demethylation
although at the end they sort of reverse
similar levels we see an increase in
inorganic arsenic okay so sort of
showing that this is demagulation
reaction and then finally
um
a new postdoc in my group uh Michael who
started about a month ago he's been able
to work with some of the sequencing data
that we got and shown that in fact we
are seeing a stimulus of methylamine
utilizing or sort of the metal
transferase is used by methylamine
um
uh methylamine utilizing ethnical
antigens okay uh suggesting that we did
that we did effectively stimulate that
Community where we also saw enhancement
I mean so
um there's a lot more to come here I got
this figure like listened to see
yesterday
um so we're just getting started
we'll make Theta and you're pregnant
data
the last Point here is sort of thinking
about
New Perspectives on how Dom may impact
microbial Transformations arsenic sort
of one new one new role here is the role
that dum complains stabilizing colloids
okay
cells
um Tom that is biolay bio it can inhibit
cellular arsenic uptake I work a tablet
oppression like mechanism That's Right
theory that we're testing
some support for this but it's whenever
we're not seeing all of our deodorantual
showing that so initially
and then finally you know thinking about
the role of sort of methyl containing
carbon compound ethanol methylamines uh
and substrates from Metroid advantages
that may also then contribution or
stimulate
okay so that's it uh thanks so much for
coming thanks for your attention I'm
happy to take
questions I just want to put you know
knowledge funders and also the four
students and postdoc to two postdocs and
two students
the main people who actually did most of
this work including Heron who is back
there in front of really awesome job so
thanks again
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu